[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
the honest answers to your Bible
questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
would you like to hear an amazing fact
On February 15 2013 the chili evinced
meteor surprised everybody when it shot
across the sky over Russia exploding 18
miles above the earth in a blast thirty
times brighter than the Sun the 65 foot
wide rock roughly the size of a five
bedroom home weighed 14,000 tons making
it heavier than the Eiffel Tower it's
estimated the meteor was traveling at
42,000 miles an hour when it entered the
atmosphere
producing an explosion what about the
same kinetic energy 30 times that of the
atomic bomb that struck Hiroshima about
1500 people were treated for injuries
mostly from flying class caused by the
shock wave that blew out windows in the
area the flash from the Super Bowl light
meteor was so bright many nearby
observers were sunburned by the radiance
strangely even though hundreds of
astronomers around the world are
constantly scanning the heavens looking
for potentially dangerous asteroids and
meteors nobody saw this one coming you
know the Bible says the second coming of
Jesus will be brighter louder and more
surprising than any random meteor stay
with his friends we're going to learn
more as amazing facts brings you this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
says that's one eight hundred four six
three seventy to ninety seven let's get
to our first Bible question with pastor
Doug Batchelor and our co-host pastor
Jean Ross evening friends this is Bible
answers live are very thankful you've
tuned in for this international
interactive Bible study and tonight Wow
lines are wide open if you have a Bible
question good chance if you call now
you'll get your question on tonight's
program the number 800 God says that's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we'll bring your Bible
question live to our studio one more
time you're ready eight hundred four six
three seven two ninety seven if you have
a Bible question this program is
dedicated to searching the word and my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening listening friends and
pastor Doug as usual let's stop the
program with prayer dear Father in
Heaven we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up the
Bible and study together we ask your
blessing upon math this program be with
those listening Lordan beat us all
together into a clearer understanding of
the Bible in Jesus name Amen amen
pastor you open the program by talking
about this meteor that came down over
Russia and is rather remarkable the
power of this meteor the size of the
meteor and then the suddenness with
which this thing came nobody really
expected it yeah and it goes that quite
an explosion I guess we every one can be
grateful that it didn't actually hit hit
the ground but it sounded like it
exploded above above the earth yeah and
you know there's a number of u2's of
probably thousands of them because a lot
of cars in Russia have dash cams and
then you just see the sky lighting up
it's like you know a nuclear blast the
the and it was in the daytime it got
much brighter than the Sun and the other
thing is a lot of offices had cameras
for whatever reason and to see the panic
in people's faces when the windows blew
out and they saw this bright light they
thought it was the end of the world they
just weren't ready and so you know it
just made me think well someday there is
going to be a big surprise Jesus tells
us in such an hour you think not the Son
of Man is coming of course none of us
really knows how long we're gonna live
not everybody gets a note from the
doctor that tells them they've got six
months left to live a lot of people die
suddenly and so you need to be ready
jesus said in Matthew 24:27
speaking of his return for his Lightning
comes from the east and shines as far as
the west so will the coming of the Son
of man be this meteor there in Russia it
has lit up the whole sky for hundreds of
miles even in other countries could see
that and just the the flaming brightness
nobody had to elbow you and say did you
see that because it was so bright well
the brightness of the Lord's coming will
be even brighter and Jesus tells us
therefore be ready for the Son of Man is
coming at an hour you do not expect it's
going to be a surprise and friends we
have a book that tells not only about
the certainty of Jesus return but a lot
of folks are confused about how he's
coming back there's a lot of
misunderstandings about what's going to
happen with the Lord's coming and we've
got a free book that talks about that
and pastor Ross is gonna tell us about
that it's a book called anything but
secret it's all about the second coming
it'll give you some great scriptural
references and also signs associated
with the coming and how Jesus will come
we're gonna give that to anybody who
calls our resource phone number and ask
for it again the book is called anything
but secret and the phone number is 883
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the book anything but secret so
again here is the number hope you're
ready
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you know pastor Doug we got
an email in the office this past week
and somebody was listening to Bible
answers live and they said we really
enjoy the program
but you guys talk so quick when you give
out that number I don't have time to
write it down so we're gonna do it one
more time here it is eight hundred eight
three five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone number if you'd like to call ask
for the book anything but secret and if
you have a Bible question the phone
number here to the studio is 800 four
six three seven two nine seven yep
that's 800 four six 372 97 first call of
this evening is Michael listening in
Henderson Kentucky Michael welcome to
the program how you doing well how are
you blessed and your question tonight
yes I have a question it's the world
well first of all everything God made in
the beginning was good if you look in
Genesis chapter one two it says
everything God made it said it was good
good good God makes his creatures free
and among the highest of God's creatures
intelligent creatures that he made was a
beautiful angel by the name of Lucifer
and Lucifer because he was a free moral
agent he became jealous he began to
regret that he didn't have more power
and the powers of God he basically
rebelled against God and just consumed
with selfishness and he was evicted from
heaven he came to our world and shortly
after it was created enticed the
original people Adam and Eve to listen
to him instead of God and sort of set up
headquarters here on this planet so the
Lord doesn't just completely destroy the
devil because he doesn't want his beings
to serve Him out of fear he wants us to
serve Him out of love because what he's
asking is reasonable and so what you're
seeing happen on this planet and it's
almost over
this world has been a stage to
demonstrate to the world that the
universe the result of living for
selfishness and that's a you know that's
a short answer but we really actually
have a video that talks all about why is
there evil in the world if God is good
if God is powerful I've just been doing
a series on Jobe at our church where it
talks about this bad
between good and evil and why God allows
suffering but if you go and look up
cosmic conflict Michael on the Internet
cosmic conflict you'll see a video we've
produced you can probably watch it for
free online now it's been out for a few
years where you can order one from us
and it explains about the fall of
Lucifer and this has been the Christian
teaching on the subject for many years
you know we also have a book dealing
with the subject called did God create a
devil it's actually an amazing fact
study guide Michael will be able to send
this to you or anybody wanting to learn
more as to why there is evil in the
world if God is a God of love why do bad
things happen to good people I think
you'll find the study guide very
informative the number to call for the
study guide is 883 five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the study
guide called did God create the devil if
you have a Bible question the phone
number here to the studio is 800 four
six three seven two nine seven and next
caller is let's see
Golda listening from a Washington Golda
welcome to the program good day on June
first there was the opening of the
Gosford tunnel in Switzerland it's taken
17 years to build and four miles under
the earth you know you're always gonna
do that as amazing fact you took it from
me that was next week that's good it's a
it's an amazing tunnel it's an amazing
tunnel but what was even more amazing
was the satanic ritual of opening the
tunnel what they do I didn't see that
yeah no more are they you know cutting a
ribbon and and doing speeches there is
this whole satanic celebration going on
and it's really quite disturbing I can
certainly link you to the link that I
have but you're talking about Satan with
previous caller this is like a huge
opening here here the Swiss are are
celebrating this
including having parts of the people
that died and eight people died and they
have you know part of the ceremony about
them and there's things flying there's
Devil's horns there's nearly naked
people there the whole the whole thing
is all about Satan there's even a man
dressed in a costume so how would you
frame this as a question then my
question is what is going on I mean how
I mean has something opened that this is
what biblical passages can be shown that
this is an opening to this kind of
satanic stuff that is going to be
happening more and more well I'll tell
you that the more that some of these
countries and we're not immune in North
America continue to make laws that choke
off the proclamation of the gospel and
they support this humanistic agenda
making man really to God of the world
it's not surprising you'll you'll start
seeing more and more ceremonies and
things that seem to have tinges of the
satanic rituals there is a verse in the
Bible where Paul says in first
Corinthians 10:20 but I say that the
things that the Gentile sacrifice they
sacrifice to devils and not to God and I
would not that you should have
fellowship with Devils and and also in
verse 21 you cannot drink the cup of the
Lord and the cup of devils you can't be
partakers at the Lord's table and the
table of devils invariably when Jesus
said if you're not with me you're
against me and as nations and people
reject the principles of the gospel the
only thing left is if they're not with
grace there were the enemy and they
usually slip into wicked diabolical
practices and services so gold I I can I
haven't seen what you're talking about
specifically I can probably search it
and find it online but yeah it doesn't
surprise me I see stuff like that in
Europe I was in Switzerland not too long
go hey I appreciate your call we do have
that that same study guy that talks
about the gun created em yeah yeah well
for that is eight hundred eighty three
five six seven four seven you can answer
the study guide called did God create a
devil next caller is Leonor listening
from Walla Walla Washington
Lenore welcome to the program thank you
I didn't thank you for taking my call
there is something that I cannot
understand and that is the Blessed
Trinity I just can't get it through my
head how three can be in one well you've
had three persons and they make up God
they are distinct individual persons now
there's obviously stuff about the
Trinity that I'm sure we can't
understand just because the Lord says as
the heavens are high above the earth so
are my ways above your ways and then the
Bible tells us God is passed finding out
or beyond the finding out and there's a
number of verses in the Bible that just
tell us that you know God there's some
mysteries that make God God but what we
do know is that there are three distinct
persons that compose what we call God
even a creation God said let us make man
in our image God the Father the Son and
the Spirit at the baptism of Jesus for
instance you see Jesus
he's got the son he's in the water and
then you hear God the Father say this is
my beloved son and at that same moment
the Holy Spirit God the Spirit is coming
down
and Jesus says now in the form of a dove
there's the spirit sometimes he doesn't
have a body like the father and son and
so sometimes he's compared to the Spirit
at Pentecost he was compared to fire
jesus said the spirit is like a wind
there's all these ethereal nebulous kind
of symbols because the Holy Spirit
doesn't seem to walk around like God the
father and son were the body even in
Genesis when you know God's making the
world says the spirit moved on the face
of the waters so he sometimes as
symbolized a dove was a symbol of peace
that was used there but the Holy Spirit
is a spirit
and so he's definitely informed yeah you
know what else is interesting is there
are two different words that we find in
the Hebrew for one now there's a famous
verse in the Old Testament that says
hear o Israel the Lord thy God is one
but the word therefore one is in a
plural form so it doesn't mean one in
numbers but rather one in purpose again
the Bible says for this reason a man
shall leave his father and his mother
and shall be joined unto his wife and
the two shall become one so the idea of
oneness is not only you know in our
terms we think of one numerical value
but one can also mean a unity of purpose
and focus the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit all one in their desire to
save mankind and they're all working
towards that goal you know we do have a
book we can send you a free copy of
lenore and it's called the Trinity is it
biblical and it takes a number of verses
in the Bible and some analogies to help
us understand and we'll be happy to send
you actually anybody that is interested
if they'd like a copy the number to call
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called the Trinity again I got the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
as for the book on the Trinity we'll be
happy to send that to you if you have a
Bible question the number is 800 four
six three seven two nine seven and next
holy is Robert listening from
Pennsylvania Robert welcome to the
program Robert G on the air hi thank you
very much for taking my call my question
is if you have any advice or any
biblical passages that you could cite
somebody who is trying to strengthen and
solidify their faith but still can't
help but to doubt and is having trouble
completely giving themselves over to
faith if that makes sense
yeah no it makes perfect sense I think
everybody has moments of doubt and as
long as there's gonna be a devil out
there you know if Jesus is all about
faith and the devil is about doubt even
the devil tried to get Jesus to doubt
his mission he said if you're the son of
well that very word if implies doubt and
pastor Ross is at Romans 10 where it
says faith comes by hearing and hearing
by the Word of God and it might be 10:17
I'm trying to remember but yeah yeah it
through the Word of God we can
strengthen our faith yeah
Romans 10:17 and so one is if you have
regular time in the word the other is
spending time in prayer because as you
talk to God and he answers your prayers
I'll just give you an example real quick
okay how do you get faith stronger I was
out riding in the Hills on a quad in the
woods I had my cell phone a fairly new
phone I just signed up for they're not
cheap smartphone bounced off the bike
off in the grass way up in the mountains
when I realized I'd lost the phone I
said alright Lord I know it's a long
shot but I'm gonna pray that you help me
find it and I just began to retrace my
steps and as just a miracle I found the
phone there in the grass if you saw the
country I'm talking about you'd know it
was a miracle I got off my bike got on
my knees and I said thank you Lord my
faith was stronger because I prayed I
saw a miraculous answer and I realized
that could not happen by accident there
is a God and I can tell you many many
stories of where you you know I've
prayed for things and you know God
doesn't want us to just pray for the
basics pray for hard to do things and if
you pray for miraculous difficult things
God gives you answers you say wow he's a
powerful God so Bible reading
strengthens your faith prayer and then
sharing your faith as you give the truth
to others it's it settles in your own
mind and you know as you give it away
it's like when the disciples gave the
bread to others it multiplied in their
hands as we share Christ with others
it'll multiply in our hands and your
faith will grow and so those are the
main three disciplines of the Christian
life is reading the word prayer and
witnessing letting your light shine
perfect thank you so much all right
thank you now we do have a book that may
help strengthen your faith a little bit
and it's called the ultimate resource
will
you a free copy if you ask again the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called the ultimate resource 808 thirty
five sixty seven forty seven we have
Imogene listening in New York
Imogene walking to the program we to be
saying well let me answer your question
there there are going to be some people
in heaven that were not baptized because
they didn't know or they could not be
like there's this thief on the cross who
died next to Jesus Jesus said you'll be
with me in paradise but he couldn't come
off the cross and get baptized but why a
believer would not be baptized makes me
wonder if they're willing to obey
because Jesus said whoever believes and
I'm quoting you from Matt or mark
chapter 16 whoever believes in his
baptized will be saved so baptism is as
important to a Christian as a wedding is
to a marriage if a person says well I
want to be married well you need to have
the wedding and baptism is the ceremony
by which we're publicly admitting and
confessing that we accept Christ and we
accept his forgiveness so why a person
wouldn't want to be baptized is what my
concern is well I agree with what you're
saying
I just wanted be reassured that I have
it straight because I was baptized you
know by words what they called
spiritually you know a commitment that
that I swear that I believe in Jesus
Christ as my Lord God the Savior but
I've never been that's right in the
water
Israel well yeah of course in order to
go to heaven you want to be saved you
can't go to heaven if your loss
I know I know you're in theology I I do
said it is theologian but I have to get
it straight in my eggs in other words
once I'm baptized and I accept Jesus as
my Lord God you say yes and my name is
written in the book of life and I'm
stuck and I then I go to heaven if you
have surrendered your heart to Jesus and
you have accepted his forgiveness for
your sins and you're baptized now you
should be baptized I heard you say you
were baptized by someone speaking words
the Bible says you should be immersed in
water there's nothing in the Bible talks
of a word met word baptism and so it
sounds like you're going to Israel and
you're going to do a water baptism
that's very good but if we've
surrendered we're following the Lord and
we're baptized yes you have eternal life
is the promise it's a daily experience
we do have a book dealing with the
subject called baptism is it really
necessary
naima gene will be able to send this to
you just give us a call I think you'll
enjoy reading it the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask to the
book on baptism again baptism is it
really necessary and the phone line to
our resource number is 883 five six
seven four seven a next Kohli's gene
listening from Clear Lake Wisconsin gene
welcome to the program Oh gene you on
the air Thank You pastors yeah yes my
question tonight is I can't remember the
verses where I've heard it but I've
heard it twice know the seven
personalities of God no you always hear
the Father Son and the Holy Ghost what
are the seven personalities of God well
I think what you're talking about is
there's a verse in Revelation that talks
about the seven spirits of God it
doesn't typically use the word
personality some pastors may have
translated it that way in hee and it
gives the characteristics of God someone
might call them the personalities in
Isaiah now first of all revelation talks
about the seven spirits of God Isaiah 11
verse 2
I don't know if you have that dear
pastor Ross yeah it's the Spirit of the
Lord shall rest upon him that is the
spirit of wisdom and understanding the
spirit of counsel and might the spirit
of knowledge and the fear of the Lord so
if you count that up this seven
characteristics of the Spirit yeah so
that'd be an Isaiah chapter 11 verse 2
these they're kind of like the facets of
the jewel of who God's personality is
okay no wood well that's know they're
three distinct persons in other words
you may be a person with several
characteristics one person several
characteristics some of the
characteristics of God are the seven
that we just mentioned there but God the
Father Son and spirit all three have
those seven characteristics they are
unique persons there if some people
think that God you know one day he
appears as the father and then he
changes his face and the next day he
appears as a son and then later he
chooses to appear as the spirit they're
really three separate persons because in
in the baptism of Jesus you see them all
appear at the same time and unless Jesus
is you know being a ventriloquist
they're distinct separate ID
personalities or unless God talks to
himself because jesus prayed to the
Father
so God the Father Son and spirit of
three distinct persons those three
persons have some prime characteristics
that verse that we read yesterday about
when Moses said to God show me your
glory
and he identified some of the
characteristics of the Lord
long-suffering so forth you know the
verse we just read in Isaiah chapter 11
verse 2 it's characteristics of the holy
spirit but it's also Missy any prophecy
and it's talking about the Messiah or
Christ where it says the Spirit of the
Lord shall rest upon him that's raised a
capital him so Christ the Holy Spirit
the father share these same
characteristics or qualities yep I hope
that helps a little bit Jean you might
also enjoy that book that we're offering
on the subject
the Trinity we have time for one more
quick call before a break but Peter is
listening from Arizona pita welcome to
the program good evening how are you
gentlemen dude well I I believe that
once saved always saved but my friends
who are another denomination tell me
that I am dead wrong and I can lose my
salvation if I commit certain sins which
they of course won't explain to me which
ones and I would like to get your take
on it all right hey I appreciate your
asking that question it is a
controversial question we certainly
don't want to do anything to diminish
from another person's confidence I
believe a Christian can know he has
eternal life which is what it tells us
in first John but you could also do
things where you turn away from the Lord
and you have several examples in the
Bible the people that once walked with
the Lord and turned away a Peter talks
about the Sal that was washed it returns
to wallowing in the mire and the dog
returns through its vomit and you've got
Balaam who was a prophet of God and he
through greed grieved away the Holy
Spirit King Saul was prophesying under
the influence of God's Spirit but
through pride he grieved away the Holy
Spirit Judas was one of the Apostles but
because of his greed he sold the Savior
for silver and he ended up hanging
himself and so it's reckless to say
though just because you come to the Lord
and you once accept the Lord that then
you cannot lose your salvation and we've
got a book we'll send you a free copy
can a saved man be lost call a resource
number and we'll send that to you Peter
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion southeast Ohio faith oxygen Tian
Shan Joey China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you
did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word
go deeper visit the amazing Bible
timeline at Bible history.com every
bible question you have answered moves
you one step closer to the fullness of
God's will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred seven eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven now let's join pastors Doug
Batchelor and John Ross for more Bible
answers live and if you have Bible
questions give us a call
lines open the 800 god says eight
hundred four six three seven two ninety
seven we'll bring your Bible question
into our studios if you joined us along
the way this is Bible answers live I am
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross and
again France this is a good time if you
have a Bible question give us a call we
do have some lines that are open the
number again 800 four six three seven
two nine seven our first caller in the
second half the program is Monica
listening from Brooklyn New York
Monica welcome to the program Monica
Monica you there hi we got you know
thank you for taking my call gentlemen
my question comes from first John
chapter 5 verse 16 it says if anyone
sees his brother committing a sin not
leading to death he shall ask and God
will give him life to those who commit
sins that
lead to death now my question is how
could I pray for someone who's coming in
and sit on to death how would I know
oh if that sin is on to death well you
know there's the Bible tells us there is
one sin jesus said for which there is no
forgiveness and that's the blasphemy of
the Holy Spirit other than that it tells
us in Matthew 12 and I think a couple of
other places all manner of sin and
blasphemy will be forgiven unto men but
he that blaspheme is the Holy Spirit it
will not be forgiven and so I think John
here is talking about if there's someone
out there and they've got just a
high-handed sin where they're rejecting
God and they've turned their back you
just need to you can you know move on it
so you said that would be a sin unto
death and no matter all the pearl will
help because they considered a blessing
well I don't know that we know all the
time you got to be very careful about
saying I know this person is blaspheming
the Holy Spirit John is just saying you
know there's one sin that I'm not saying
you should pray for it but who knows
when a person has committed that sin I
don't I mean you know there's people I
would have given up on a long time ago
in the Bible and I look at and what God
does and then he saves him I think about
King Manasseh who was a wicked King for
you know 40 years 50 years and killed
the Prophet and some of his own children
were sacrificed to Devils and just a
wicked King and you'd never would have
thunk that here he repented in an
assyrian jail and turned back to the
Lord I would have given up on him long
ago
and so there's others you know he'd you
just surprised so it's best to continue
to pray for them even if we even if we
suspect like you say we can't know for
sure cause we can't see their heart well
you know this is probably a place to
apply that scripture where Jesus said
don't cast your pearls before swine or
give us holy to the dogs sometimes
you've got so much time in the day to
work for people and so much time to pray
for people and if there's somebody that
is just you know putting up a stone wall
and they're just not interested
then you know you stop praying for them
and you pray for those that are
interested because you've got so many
prayers you can pray you know what I
mean we were not God we have so much
time in the day to pray and you may as
well pray for those who are open as
opposed to those who just you know they
seem to be shutting the doors thank you
so much answer my question
all right well thank you very much
appreciate that Monica we have Charlotte
listening from Washington Charlotte walk
to the program thank you thank you very
much for taking my call really nervous
is my first time calling oh don't be
nervous
we're nice guys I know that's why I'm
calling you could set a light on a Bible
verse that I've been actually just kind
of trying to understand for a long time
it's found in first Peter 3:21 and the
verse before is talking about how when
says when once the long-suffering of God
waited in the days of Noah so it's
talking about how Noah was aged and you
know the ark was being built and so
forth and then it says in verse 21 the
like figure wearing to even baptism doth
also now save us not the putting away of
the filth of the flesh and I guess my
question is it almost sounds like in
that verse is saying that baptism saves
us so you know I guess I'm kind of I
don't feel like I don't understand but
you know what it's actually saying there
and then not putting in the way of the
filter the flesh because I know when we
accept Christ you know he changes us oh
yeah well you know he puts his right to
law in our hearts and their minds when
we become a new creature so yeah I was
just wondering if you can shed some
light on that for me I'll do my best it
is a difficult verse but first of all
Peter is making a comparison to the
whole world was destroyed with a flood
the ark went through the water which is
a symbol of baptism only those who went
through the water there in the ark were
saved and just like the children of
Israel had to go through the sea Paul
says that's a symbol of baptism that's
in first Corinthians chapter 10
and you know the children of Israel were
baptized in the sea and then the pillar
of fire so they were baptized in the
fire and the water Christ said unless
you're born of the water and the spirit
you cannot enter the kingdom of heaven
now Peters making the point when he said
not the putting away of the filth of the
flesh so it's not that we're saved by
works but it's by the answer of a good
conscience towards God meaning that when
we are baptized
we're coming part of baptism is
repenting remember John the Baptist when
they came to get baptized he said he
preached a message of repentance sorrow
for sin the kingdom of heaven is at hand
repentance means a turning away from sin
and a willingness to walk in a newness
of life and so Peters assuming that
those who understand what baptism is all
about are repenting of their sins and
accepting by faith the forgiveness of
Jesus then they live in a newness of
life and the the filth of the flesh is
put away high and they've got a clear
conscience towards God because of faith
then he talks about by the resurrection
of Jesus Christ the same way Christ came
to life Paul said baptism is a symbol of
death burial and resurrection so Peter
here is I think playing on the same
thing that Paul says about baptism it's
a symbol of death burial and
resurrection as Jesus was raised we come
out of the water to walk in a newness of
life okay yeah that definitely helps I
like the ring well thank you yeah it's a
deep verse but we have a lesson we'll be
happy to send you on the subject of
baptism that sounds like you understand
it but I think it touches on this a
little bit and I think it'd be a
blessing if you'd like a copy all right
thank you very much Charlotte pastor
also give you the number all right thank
you you're welcome
well study God is called purity and
power talks about baptism and again
we'll send it to anybody who calls an
ass the number is 883 five six seven
four seven 883 567 forty-seven yes for
the study guide called purity and power
a next call a spat listening from
Michigan Pat welcome to the program
hello evening thanks for calling
I'm glad I'm glad you can watch I
wanna call about how much you know in
the last days with the two witnesses in
the Enoch and Elijah is because they
didn't die before no some people say
that the two witnesses are Enoch and
Elijah because that verse says it's
appointed unto man wants to die and they
say well they didn't die so they must be
the two witnesses that will die and be
left in the streets and that's sort of
the logic behind picking them but if you
think about it Pat for a moment
Enoch and Elijah now have glorified
bodies they've entered into eternity
they're not going to now get mortal
bodies that die and have to rise again
there are a few that you know were
favored we only know about Enoch and
Elijah in the Bible they did not
experience death like everyone else we
know there's gonna be some people that
don't die when Christ comes cuz Paul
says those of us who are alive when
Jesus comes we'll be caught up to meet
the Lord in the air we never are we
never die those who are alive and remain
when Christ comes will be transformed
we're caught up and we meet the Lord in
the air so when people argue and say it
has to be Enoch and Elijah they're the
two witnesses because they haven't died
yet they have to die that argument
doesn't really hold water because
there's a whole group of people that
don't die when Jesus comes
I believe the two witnesses represent
some people say Moses and Elijah but
Moses and Elijah are a type of the law
and the prophets the two witnesses are
the Word of God if you said the new in
the Old Testament that would be true the
law and the prophets it's a sword with
two edges zechariah talks about the two
candlesticks by the throne of god it's
his word that he sent forth into all the
earth it's and both revelation 11 were
talks about the two witnesses and
zechariah chapter 4 i think it is pastor
ross where it talks about the two
candlesticks and two olive trees well
thy word is a lamp unto my feet that's
why he said it's a candlestick and so it
says these two witnesses have the power
to proclaim plagues and to shut up the
heavens while that's in the Word of God
new in the Old Testament Zechariah 4
yeah the faster you're thinking about
there
so we do have a book we'll send you a
book specifically on the two witnesses
and it's called the glorious mount who
are the two witnesses Pat if you'd like
a copy
no one's gonna bother you just got a
call and give the operators your number
and they'll send you that free of charge
the number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and just ask to the book
called who are the two witnesses that
glorious mount again it's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven a
next Kohli's David and he's listening
from Washington David welcome to the
program oh my goodness oh my goodness I
love you guys they were glad you got on
the air you're you're listening on radio
74 awesome good for you yeah that's a
that's a friend of ours that runs that
yeah I listen you guys for the last five
years let me love you anyway when I'm
trying to talk to my brother who is a
non-believer and that the Bible is not
just a legendary embellishment he always
catches me on the quote from Jesus where
he tells the disciples that some of them
will be alive when he returns and that's
where he doesn't believe in the Bible he
thinks it you know that can't be true
maybe I'm no you know there I've heard
people say that but that's actually in
the Bible John clears that up and he
says he didn't say that that's a
misunderstanding
in other words if you look in John
chapter 21 verse 21 that's easy to
remember John 21 21 okay Peter and Peter
and John are walking with Jesus after
Jesus rose from the dead
Peter seen John walking behind he said
to Jesus Lord what will this man do
what's gonna happen to him because Jesus
had just told Peter you're gonna be
crucified jesus said to him if I will
that he tarry still I come what is that
to you follow me now John goes on to say
then this saying went abroad among the
Brethren that that disciple should not
die yet Jesus did not say to him you
will not die but he said if I tear if I
will that he tarry till i come what is
that to me jesus never told the Apostles
that some of you are going to be alive
when I
come back matter of fact Paul said that
falling that the coming of the Lord
won't happen unless there's a falling
away and Paul knew he was gonna die
before Jesus came back and Paul lived
Paul was younger than most of the
apostles because he was converted
three-and-a-half years after the others
so the idea that Jesus told the Apostles
you're gonna be alive when I come back
he didn't say that
so yeah read um John 21 21 that whole
passage there I will can I throw quickly
match everybody keeps asking me who
created God where God comes from well
that is a well that's one of those
mysteries but I'm not worried about it
because even those who don't believe in
God evolutionists but say all of the
intricate organization and design and
symbiotic relationships we see in
creation you say well where did it all
come from and they'll say well you know
the Sun exploded and that formed our
solar system where'd that come from well
there was a supernova and it formed our
gallon
where'd that come from they get to a
place where they say we don't know
something always existed so we're
believing that there was an intelligent
God that made intelligent things they're
believing all this intelligence has come
from nothing that's harder to believe I
tell everybody that that evolution that
origin of the species is a bunch of
monkey business
all right preciate it
bye bye annex collies hey loo listening
from Silver Spring Maryland
Hayley welcome to the program thank you
thank you I get appreciate it thank you
[Music]
wondering why the Jews are still God's
favorite people in spite of the
rejection they demonstrate my limited
knowledge I try to explain but how would
you explain
the Samaritan woman at the well and this
is John chapter four she was arguing
with Jesus and she said you know our
fathers the Samaritans say we should
offer sacrifice on Mount Gerizim and you
Jews you say it should be on Mount Zion
and Jesus settled the question he said
to her salvation is of the Jews and Paul
says salvation to the Jew first and then
the Gentile now Paul did not say that
because he believed that the Jews that
God was showing them favoritism Paulson
that because he said God committed the
Oracles and pastor Ross might look that
up yet for unto them was committed the
Oracles of God he just type in the
Oracle Oracle's I bet you'll find that
in the King James God gave the word to
the Jews they were like the keepers of
the word and so because they knew the
word and the Jews in the world today
still have at least the Old Testament
they're not favored because of their DNA
they've been favored by exposure to the
truth those that listen to the truth
nobody is saved by being Jews there's
gonna be a lot of Jews that will be lost
and being having you know blood of
Abraham doesn't save anybody
they were favored in that they had the
Word of God and they were the ones to
proclaim the Messiah which they did at
Pentecost you know all the apostles were
Jewish and those who believed at
Pentecost were all Jewish and they took
the gospel around the world to the
Gentiles as well as the Jews so Jews can
be saved today just like anyone else but
they must believe in the Savior you know
Jesus said and John the Baptist don't
don't think to say into yourself we're
children of Abraham
God can raise up children to Abraham
from the stones and over and over Christ
said many will come from the east and
the west and sit down in the kingdom
with Abraham Isaac and Jacob and the
natural children of the kingdom they'll
be in out of darkness so it's a mistake
for anybody to think because my
ancestors were Jews or for Gentiles if
we say well my ancestors they go to
church my grandfather was a pastor and
that means God's going to save me God
doesn't save anyone like that the Bible
says he is no respecter of persons
he's made of one blood all nations
now I have a book that I'll send you a
free copy do you find that verse faster
us I have a book I'll send you a free
copy called spiritual Israel and it
answers this question clearly and how do
you say your name hi Lou hi okay yeah
well you know all you do is call the
resource number it's in Romans you find
it yeah Romans 3 verse 2 yeah
unto them was committed the Oracles of
God and will send you that book
spiritual Israel the number to call is
808 three five six seven four seven you
can answer the book called spiritual
Israel we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks again that's
883 five six seven four seven and I next
coli's Barbara listening from South
Carolina Barbara welcome to the program
hi hi good evening I'm driving so I'm
afraid I don't have the exact scripture
citation but in the books of Samuel I've
been reading a lot about David's life
and the second time he had an
opportunity to kill Saul yeah and didn't
they talked and salt that I know you
will be king and asked David to be kind
to his family and David agreed yes and
then later on the Gibeonites I believe
had done and asked David for some of
Saul's grandsons and I believe he gave
them seven of them which they hanged and
I was wondering how David reconciled
that with his promise to Saul yeah well
actually the the ones and maybe pastor
also look this up I'm trying to remember
it's it's in it maybe in second Samuel
where there's a there's a famine in the
land in the days of David and David is
asking why and God it says because of
Saul's wrath against the Gibeonites and
the Gibeonites said we don't want a
ransom of money but we want they we
wanted retaliation on the ones that
tried to exterminate us and evidently
saw in some of his family he had several
sons through concubine Saul not only had
johnathan a minute dad Malka schewe his
sons through his wife he had some
concubines sons so these are not
grandsons I saw their sons of Saul and
they were part of the plan they urged
their father to attack the Gibeonites as
he was getting older this is before he
died in battle of course so when David
gave these sons over to be executed for
what they had done they were really
paying for the genocide that they had
brought on the Gibeonites it wasn't that
they were arbitrarily being killed
because they were related to Saul David
did spare many of Saul's children Saul
had asked David don't wipe out my seed
and the David honored mephibosheth came
and lived in the palace the son of
Jonathan yeah you'll read that story in
2nd samuel chapter 21 the whole chapter
that talks about the experience of the
gibbehhh' nights so does that help a
little bit Barbara yes it does thank you
very much god bless all right thank you
appreciate your call that's a good
question my next caller is Joseph
listening from Queens New York
Joseph welcome to the program now you do
a gentleman first-time caller
thank you so much for your service you
guys have helped me out tremendously
well thank you we're glad that you've
called in my questions on Matthew 51:27
51 through 53 after Jesus died what is
that resurrection that takes place was
it like ye it says that the graves are
opened that many bodies of the saints
what fall asleep were raised and coming
out of the graves at this resurrection
they went into the holy city and
appeared to many I'm you know what
exactly does that mean I think so he's
confused me well it is a good question
this is only mentioned in the Gospel of
Matthew John Mark Luke don't mention
this story but evidently at the same
earthquake that shook the ground when
Jesus died graves were shaken open and a
number of people in Jerusalem reported
that after Sunday morning after Christ
rose some of the patriarchs and saints
that had been buried around Jerusalem
this is not a general resurrection it's
a very special small group
you know Isaiah the prophet might have
been in that group and others that had
died in the area God honored them and he
took sort of a trophy to heaven with him
those some faithful servants that were
redeemed and they went into the city and
appeared to certain people and you know
it caused quite a stir but it was a
short specialized resurrection of a few
Saints you know there's an interesting
verse in Ephesians chapter 4 and it's
verse 8 it's actually quoting from the
Old Testament this is Paul and he says
therefore he saith when he that Jesus
ascended on high and it's went back to
heaven he led captivity captive and gave
gifts unto men so you have the the idea
that when Jesus went up to heaven he led
those who were held captive by death
those who were resurrected least a
certain group they ascended up with
Jesus after his resurrection kind of
like a firstfruits of what was going to
be the general resurrection when the
Lord descends from heaven so yes
interesting story that group would be in
heaven now yes absolutely
very well wait it doesn't say who they
are just that one more little thought on
that
you know David was buried in Jerusalem
but he's not in that group because Peter
says in Acts chapter 2 David is dead and
buried as tomb is with us to this day
and he's not yet ascended to heaven so
under the inspiration the Holy Spirit
Peter said no David wasn't in that group
it was a small group good question
appreciate that Joe sorry well an
ex-police Andy listening from
Pennsylvania sandy welcome to the
program hi good evening thank you for
taking my call
quick question I've heard different
teachings about blaspheming the holy
spirit one included was that we could no
longer do it because lack seeming was
attributing the miracles of Christ to
Satan so can you give me an accurate and
concise definition of blasphemy and how
we can or cannot do it to this day yeah
and by the way you'll find that in
Matthew chapter 12 you can start with
verse 31
it says anyone who speaks a word against
the Son of man it'll be forgiven him
whoever speaks against the Holy Spirit
it will not be forgiven him either in
this age or the age to come
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit would
be a sin that God cannot forgive because
it's a sin for which you will not repent
if a person persists in resisting the
working of the Spirit in their life they
can grieve away the Holy Spirit it
usually doesn't happen in a day it
doesn't even happen in a year but when
someone continues to resist the Holy
Spirit they are gradually turning down
the radio that is giving them the alarm
telling them to turn to God and finally
when that radios off there's nothing
more the Lord can do so it's not any
particular sin but it's resisting the
Holy Spirit in any area of your life now
we do have a book pastor Ross that talks
about that blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit and we'll send you a free copy
sandy if you just call that number
number to Coley's 808 three five six
seven four seven you can ask the book
that talks about blasphemy against the
Holy Spirit god bless you friends make
sure and go check out amazing facts dot
o-r-g have some important announcements
coming your way stand by
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history or what recent world
events are harbingers of the end are you
ready for the coming crisis landmarks of
prophecy offers clear answers to your
most pressing questions presented by
pastor Doug Batchelor landmarks of
prophecy is a contemporary video Bible
study adventure designed for today's
audiences presenting the landmark themes
of the Bible and a bright and compelling
way helping you understand the Bible
better and giving you knowledge to face
the future with conference landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling 877-709-7899
[Music]
have you ever heard the expression
before they eat like a bird talking
about somebody that has a miniscule
appetite well you might want to think
twice next time you use that expression
for example take the hummingbird in
order for it to maintain its incredible
metabolism it has to eat about 50% of
its body weight every day to put that in
perspective if a hundred pound woman was
to eat like a hummingbird she would have
to eat 50 pounds of sugar a day just to
maintain her body weight imagine then
maybe you don't want to imagine that but
perhaps we want to consider this another
way the hummingbird typically consumes
between 4 to 7 calories a day on the
other hand a human about 3500 calories a
day but if you were to eat like a bird a
hummingbird you'd have to eat over a
hundred and fifty thousand calories a
day but that's like a man 170 pounds
that would be eating 3000 Oreo cookies
under normal conditions a hummingbird
needs to eat every 5 or 10 minutes but
there's actually one time during the
year the hummingbird will eat its entire
body weight every day you see once a
year they make this migration 500 mile
once the Gulf of Mexico from Texas to
the Yucatan Peninsula
in order to do that the hummingbird
feasts on nectar and gorges themselves
on this nectar for about a week
doubling their body weight that's the
only way they can store enough calories
to help them with their 70 wingbeats per
second a roughly 4 million wingbeats on
that journey you know in the same way
friends as we near the end of time we
need to be feasting and gorging
ourselves on the nectar of god's word
we've got to be able to have that
strength to get us through the times of
trouble that are ahead so when it comes
to the Bible and your personal devotions
if you're gonna eat like a bird eat like
a hummingbird
[Music]
for over 50 years amazing facts has
shared the wonderful news of salvation
and provided millions of Bible resources
to people all over the world we've built
churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website at amazing facts dot o-r-g
[Music]